when I see you playing Nederland damage
and you were just rehearsing and stuff
and I how did you learn how to be so
proficient at the guitar do you think
you're just sort of a musical genius I'm
not I'm certainly not great but I have a
certain idiom it's my deal it works for
me and the damage done hard to play is
that a difficult song because you do the
whole thing you pick through the whole
song um when I first tried to learn it
when I was a kid it was hard because
it's slightly syncopated but it's not
that hard why do you like this song it
makes me sad as all music does and the
sad are the better for me and I love
Neil Young but it wrecks me every time I
hear it and I don't even know why it
just has to do with damaged people
mm-hmm and damaged people I always think
I have to save them what attracted you
to this song I think I identify I'm
similar to you I identify with the The
Misfits in a way I feel bonded to them
and I think pulling yourself out of the
screaming sorrow of your losses is
heroic and I like to help people and
help myself
I don't know too many people who are
like singing needle and the damage done
but your version is amazing would you do
a little of that now don't do this I'll
try not to curly
[Music]
her to knock you know my love you baby
[Music]
damage done
hit the city and I lost number I watch
the needle take another
gone
damage
[Music]
I sing the song because I know that some
of you don't understand to keep
brahmana Nederland damaged up a little
pub isn't everyone but every junkie it's
like the settings
[Music]
the knocking on my cellar door
[Music]
damage done oh man that's really good